je prends mon pupitre voilà j'ai montré
mes chansons c'est un rituel que nous
refait chaque jour quand elle rentre des
cours à 13 ans cette collégienne de
maurepas a décidé de se lancer dans
l'aventuré the voice kids une émission
de télé crochet qu'elle a l'habitude de
regarder en famille
il ya deux ans j'ai demandé à maman si
je pouvais faire et ce qu'ils aiment a
vu dit que j'étais trop jeune pour le
faire que vous avez pas encore enfin la
voix pour le faire et du coup
donc j'ai attendu un an non je me suis
entraîné et tout et puis il ya un an
après j'ai demandé à maman qu'elle
envoie une vidéo
[Musique]
et c'est quelque chose chez elle de
vital presque de chanter donc je sais
que elle en a besoin qu'elles adorent ça
depuis toute petite elle a toujours
chanté même tout bébé
nour n'a jamais pris de cours de chant
et pourtant sa voix a fait la différence
parmi les vingt mille vidéos reçues par
la production
après avoir franchi différentes étapes
elle est sélectionnée pour les auditions
à l'aveuglent l'émission a été
enregistrée il ya un an
si au départ sa maman était sereine à la
pression se fait de plus en plus
présente
je me suis pas trop posé de questions je
stressais pas encore trop c'est plutôt
sait même pas trop pendant le tournage
de l'émission mais c'était que c'est
plutôt après que les questions arrivent
on s'est plutôt des questions
voilà deux mamans quoi qui veut
préserver
voilà sa fille cas que 13 ans même si
elle fait plus et pour savoir si nous re
continue l'aventuré the voice kid
rendez vous devant votre petit écran le
vendredi 20 septembre
[Musique]